allez vivre
ça madame
à l'horizon 2026 de 2007 parce que comme
je vous l'expliquer tout à l'heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais pu me tuer puis moi ben
j'aurais pu vu mes enfants mes
petits-enfants étaient depuis fin
novembre maintenu dans un centre
éducatif pour une durée de 6 mois mais
ce matin en colère contre la justice le
maire de Cannes David Lisnard s'est
saisi de son compte Twitter pour poster
ce message j'apprends que l'un des
agresseurs maintenus en centre éducatif
fermé c'est enfui deux des trois mineurs
avant de connaître leur peine à l'été
prochain ont été placés dans des centres
éducatifs fermés c'est à dire que là
vraiment normalement ça remplace la
prison mais il y a une équipe éducative
c'est clos ils n'ont pas le droit de
sortir ils sont soumis à des mesures
strictes et l'un des deux c'est évadé
parce que c'est le bon mot ce n'est pas
le fils du monsieur qui est venu sur le
plateau c'est l'autre qui était à
Marseille dans un centre fermé il est
parti il a eu envie de retrouver sa
famille il est parti à Cannes et
heureusement le maire de Cannes a réagit
très vite police nationale police
municipale ont travaillé ensemble et il
a été arrêté en pleine ville interpellé
amené dans un commissariat à maintenant
et il sera présenté à un juge qui du
coup peut décider comme il n'a pas
respecté son contrôle judiciaire de le
placer en prison partage David Kelly tu
déjà des mecs qui s'évadent des prisons
des vrais prisons la santé freine
partout ils arrivent à s'évader donc un
centre pour éducation
arrivent les gars il s'est il s'enfuit
voilà faut le rattraper il faut qu'il
fasse à peine parce que là c'est un truc
médiatique mais il y a plein de
d'histoire qui sont pas médiatisées ou
les mecs s'enfuient et on les laisse
après on leur court pas après et on vous
dit moi ici que la jeunesse maintenant
c'est plus un mec de 14 15 16 ans c'est
plus un mec qui a 16 ans dans les années
70 je vous dis aujourd'hui des mecs de
16 17 ans c'est des Coréens faut
peut-être un peu changer de loi par
rapport à ça et moi j'aimerais bien
qu'on fasse un audit ou une enquête sur
les centres éducatifs fermés comment ça
fonctionne en France comment on est
surveillé comment on peut sortir
pourquoi les sports
qu'on met des moyens mais il y a pas de
raison en fait je ne comprends pas
pourquoi ça ne fonctionne pas ça va être
très dangereux les gens vont se faire de
plus en plus justice ça c'est une
nouvelle qui est imaginez ce sera une
circonstance aggravante malgré tout
quand quand il aura le lapin en jeu
pauvre petit mais bien sûr que non
Castaldi je trouve que c'est un problème
de justice en deux fois il y a une
première fois on reconnaît les fêtes
c'est bien on le sait et après dans 6
mois dans 8 mois on va revenir les gens
vont oublier donc la situation va
s'apaiser et je trouve ça effectivement
déplorable qu'on n'attend pas on ne
passe pas immédiatement pourquoi
attendre 6 mois ça sert à quoi sert à
rien du temps quand on va dans un centre
éducatif fermé qui a priori on l'a l'air
d'être des passoires moi j'aimerais bien
savoir les règles de sécurité puisque
apparemment c'est facile de s'en
échapper là en revanche il faut qu'il
aille en prison et tant mieux si le cas
il faut durcir les sanctions c'est
balancé
un juge il soif le renvoyer dans un
centre éducatif fermé un autre peut-être
Bordeaux a l'air plus sûr que celui dont
il s'est échappé Marseille c'est une
maison de campagne
il y a des gens honnêtes qui ne sont pas
logés comme ça en ce moment maire de
Cannes là il a été proactif il a réuni
les deux polices la justice a été très
laxiste là-dessus à mal géré si vous
dites on l'envoie pas en prison vous
l'envoyez pas dans un centre d'anti
s'évade dont il s'échappe c'est
impossible ça parce que ça va donner du
grain à moudre à tous ceux qui disent il
faut séduire plus amplement et là ce
soir je les comprends moi qui essaie
souvent de d'être un peu indulgent là il
y a aucune indulgence possible
catastrophique d'aller en prison à 16
ans parce que tu sais pas comment il va
ressortir il faut pas croire que quand
tu vas en prison à 16 ans tu ressors et
tu passes le bac ça se trouve il va
ressortir encore plus nerveux tous les
plus grands criminels ils ont été en
prison jeune ils sont ressortis ils ont
fait des tas de conneries derrière donc
moi je suis pas pour la prison à 16 ans
et je me dis mais ce mot-là qu'est-ce
qu'il a dans la tête de ce qu'on sauver
et ses parents et les parents là tu en
parlent même plus pour moi ils sont
largués les parents là on en parle même
plus des parents là
quelqu'un qui s'appelle Ivana Knoll elle
n'arrête pas de médicaments
elle fait sensation au point de créer de
véritables attroupements pourquoi pour
cette nuit c'est une supportrice croate
regardez là voilà Ivana
elle est magnifique on dirait Daniel
avant le relooking
[Rires]
et son compte Instagram
elle a explosé
à la télévision britannique assez
expliquée sur un point important
certains lui reprochent de ne pas
respecter la culture locale du Qatar en
s'habillant comme elle le fait regardez
sa réponse aujourd'hui
[Musique]
j'étais présentée à l'élection de Miss
Croatie en 2016 elle faisait partie de
2015 je suis présenté également
[Musique]
en plus du chauffage 2400 lycéens
manquent aussi désormais d'électricité à
cause de la vétusté de leur
établissement ce matin on a fait cours
dans le noir merci à Flora d'être là
vous êtes scolarisé Olivier au lycée
wallon donc ce lycée tant qu'elle classe
je suis en Première première alors
raconte nous ce qui se passe dans ton
lycée parce que nous on hallucine on est
dans des salles qui sont dans des
conditions pitoyables on n'a pas moi ça
fait trois ans que je suis au lycée
depuis et même des personnes avant moi
ils ont dit que c'était pareil ça fait
des années que ça a pas évolué du tout
j'avais trop froid on arrive dans la
salle il fait la même température à
l'intérieur de la salle que à
l'extérieur
il fait super froid et c'est horrible
par exemple Ahmed vous êtes pas on élève
autorise le manteau mais d'autres profs
non plus et ça crée des conflits il y a
des rapports qui sont en rapport parce
qu'il a pas voulu enlever son manteau je
fais les conseils de classe donc j'ai vu
le l'intérieur du lycée c'est réel c'est
pas des montages c'est vraiment vrai ce
qui se passe dans ce lycée c'est
horrible et je me demande comment les
enfants arrivent à travailler les
toilettes
il y a pas de problème
mon grand mon fils il avait besoin de
faire la grosse commission j'habite à 15
minutes à pied mais 5 minutes en voiture
il m'a appelé viens me chercher je suis
venu le chercher il a fait sa commission
à la maison et je le redéposé à l'école
aujourd'hui on va parler de celui-ci
moi je moi je comprends quand on voit ce
genre d'image même à votre place moi
j'ai été lycéen en Seine-Saint-Denis
quand on est arrivé en 2016 à la tête de
la région récupérer 270 essais vetus sur
470 en Île-de-France quand on les voit
pas et les travaux ont commencé je suis
désolé les premiers ont lieu dès 2017 en
2017 monsieur et en 2018 il y a eu des
postes de première pierre je suis allé
moi-même avec la région
mais certaines images nous donnent pas
d'aujourd'hui ici aujourd'hui
le reste c'est en rénovation on est
pleinement mobilisés
[Rires]
[Musique]
la vidéo elle date d'aujourd'hui je vous
jure
j'ai pris toutes ces vidéos aujourd'hui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y a eu des réactions d'ailleurs
dites-nous c'est quoi les autres
problèmes
étaient en spécialité physique il n'a
pas une prof de physique pendant trois
mois
il y en a pas dans 93 c'est pas vrai
vous êtes pas là moi de deux enfants qui
vont dans ce lycée H24 de 8h jusqu'à
17h30 il n'y a pas de chauffage il n'y a
pas de toilette il n'y a pas d'eau il
n'y a pas de professeur il n'y a pas de
sécurité il n'y a rien nous sommes
abandonnés par vous les élus de je peux
pas vous laisser quand on voit quand on
voit les images on est d'accord avec
elle si on est en 2022
je suis d'accord avec vous vous allez
pas choisir le carrelage non
des chiottes
Florac toi qu'est-ce que c'est lui dire
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
pardon mais quand même
depuis qu'on en a parlé hier dans
l'émission les choses commencent
apparemment à bouger puisque le ministre
de l'Éducation pas peine Guy et la
présidente de la région Valérie Pécresse
se sont rendus au lycée et apparemment
génial
juste après
15 minutes après c'est vrai que ça nous
fait plaisir
juste après l'émission à 14 minutes
après l'émission c'est froid c'est beau
c'est beau c'est très beau de réagir
mais vous permettrez quand même de
penser qu'un ministre de l'éducation
nationale par rapport à Aulnay-sous-Bois
qui a une encablure de Paris le fait
qu'il découvre ça grâce à vous c'est
quand même sinon ça fait des années non
mais ça fait des années que le lycée
dans cet état-là des années que les
parents d'élèves que l'administration
alerte et il faut qu'il regarde une
émission pour agir ça dénote une
déconnexion totale de son environnement
ça veut dire que c'était pimp qui lui
explique où faut se rendre le lendemain
il y a Gournay-sur-Marne il y a
Montfermeil il y a Épinay il y a plein
de Épinay-sur-Seine il y a plein de
lycées en 93 où j'ai eu plein de
messagers ils m'ont dit regarde le
bordel alors si tous les soirs faire
venir quelqu'un pour que le ministre il
bouge derrière alors c'est ça notre là
notre France elle est là aujourd'hui
[Musique]
à chaque fois qu'il y a des matchs avec
des équipes du Maghreb certains
supporters qui se permettent des
débordements qui sont intolérables de
son côté la mer du 8e arrondissement de
Paris qui craint elle aussi les
débordements à l'issue du match sur les
Champs-Élysées a suscité une vie
polémique en déclarant ses propos tout
le monde a peur d'une guerre d'une
guérilla et d'une guerre civile vous
êtes content du dispositif de sécurité
qui a été mis en place samedi soir après
la victoire du Maroc là c'est pas ça
c'est bien passé ou pas pour vous non
pas très bien pas très bien non pas très
bien pour mercredi vous avez bien sûr
que j'ai peur parce que comme vous le
savez je sais pas si vous connaissez le
8e arrondissement c'est ton appel le
poumon économique de la capitale il y a
37000 habitants 200000 personnes
viennent y travailler chaque jour vous
pensez bien que les commerçants les
restaurateurs tout le monde a peur et
aussi les riverains parce que j'ai quand
même des habitants les gens ne le savent
pas sur l'avenue il y a peut-être une
vingtaine mais derrière toutes ces rues
avec les écoles et tout ça donc j'ai des
habitants et ils ont tous peur de ce qui
va se passer et j'ai retraduit
effectivement leur peur vous savez qu'en
98 il y a une voiture une une personne
dans la voiture elle a paniqué et elle a
paniqué et elle a foncé 150 personnes
blessées dont deux morts donc c'est pour
éviter ce genre de choses que je demande
premièrement qu'on interdise la
circulation entre
on filtre les arrivées sur
Champs-Élysées pour empêcher que
certains casseurs il faut dire les
choses que certains casseurs arrivent
avec les mortiers parce que quand vous
venez fêter une victoire vous venez pas
avec des mortiers ni avec des barres et
tout ça voilà donc on va voir ce qui
s'est passé déjà samedi soir
[Musique]
s'ils arrivent à un million je crains si
jamais on n'arrive pas à interdire les
access sera difficile à gérer pour les
forces de l'ordre alors vous créez c'est
ce que vous craignez mercredi Gilles
tous les incidents évidemment ce qu'on
voit c'est regrettable madame la mer
mais très franchement le bilan de la
fête après la victoire du Maroc c'est
effectivement quelques tirs de mortier
inacceptables et trois scooters
incendiés de deux vitrines brisées c'est
quand même majoritairement une belle
fête qui s'est passé et la joie des
Marocains était communicative c'est
parce que je veux défendre c'est parce
que je veux défendre les les supporters
les personnes qui viennent fêter la
victoire que j'essaie de demander qui
est des mesures supplémentaires pour
éviter des débordements sauf quand vous
parlez de guerre civile là je trouve que
le mot n'est pas approprié
ce sera sans doute des Black Blocs mais
ça n'a rien à voir avec les Marocains
madame
entre les jaune et tout ce qui se passe
avec à chaque victoire de coupe du monde
je parle pas simplement marocain à
chaque fois quand il y a un
rassemblement sur les Champs-Élysées
c'est le binz la dernière fois quand ils
sont montés sur une voiture de
sentinelle de sentinelle qu'ils ont
secoué les sentinelles les mecs ils sont
quand même armés à l'intérieur
heureusement qu'ils ont pardon
heureusement ils avaient donc la
maîtrise voilà donc mais autrement il
serait descendu ça aurait été voilà une
cata je trouve que c'est normal que vous
ayez envie de protéger et les riverains
et vous administrer moi je vois pas du
tout il y a rien de stigmatisant il y a
rien de problématique j'entends déjà mon
procès à gauche de limite ses racistes
de dire ça bah en fait non mais vu la
tranche que j'ai on peut pas dire
de ce qu'elle a dit tout à l'heure elle
a dit à chaque fois qu'il y a des
manifestations sur les Champs-Élysées
voilà c'est elle parle ni du Maroc
c'est bien de
peut-être que ce ne sont pas des Black
Blocs peut-être des Marocains
sous-entends Géraldine vous
sous-entendez que c'est parce qu'ils
sont marocains ou parce qu'ils auraient
peut-être avec ça
et peu précisé voilà parce qu'elle a dit
quand il y a des matchs
chez les marocains chez les Français
arrêter tout le temps en fait toi tu as
un côté mais insupportable
rien ne pourra me salir mon Johnny rien
ou dire il peut me dire tout sur Johnny
à [ __ ] je l'aime je l'aimerai toujours
c'est incroyable voilà et ce conseil moi
c'est qu'il pouvait aussi lui arriver
alors je sais pas c'est quoi cette
histoire un des extraits qui a fait le
plus parler regardez
les infidélités c'était quoi c'était
dans les deux sens c'était tout le temps
tous les deux c'est lui qui a commencé
que je me suis vengée pour pour me
montrer que je pouvais encore séduire et
que je pouvais plaire et que et j'ai eu
un moment de faiblesse puis l'as su et
comment il a réagi je vous demande pas
parce qu'il a très très mal
a été rythmée par les diverses fidélité
alors qu'à un moment elle a dit ouais
elle s'est dit ouais je vais je vais
essayer de séduire
quand même que Laetitia aurait eu je
vais quand même utiliser le conditionnel
une aventure avec Lenny Kravitz et lui
il aurait aussi trompé plusieurs
reprises et notamment avec
Vanessa et elle avait fait la Une à
l'époque d'un célèbre magazine People et
cette jeune femme était connue notamment
pour avoir participé à une émission de
téléréalité opération séduction Caraïbes
sur M6 Jean-Claude Camus pardon mais
vous voyez beaucoup qui me disait qu'à
la fin de leur vie il n'avait même plus
de relation sexuelle des dernières
années ensemble que c'était un coup
fusionnel mais que et pour plein de
raisons parce qu'ils buvait beaucoup
parce que du coup il était moins et que
voilà et que elle elle avait un petit
moment à côté mais qu'ils étaient bien
ensemble voilà on en est où du procès
sur l'héritage tout est réglé ou pas
tout est extrêmement bien réglé depuis
déjà fort longtemps vous pouvez la les
enfants ont renoncé finalement cet
héritage certainement juste raison ils
ont renoncé la vie non je crois que
David ne voulait que tout revienne en
France pour pour quand même conserver
une sorte de droit moral sur sur les
œuvres de son père pour le reste il ne
cherchait pas à boire de l'argent et
chercher juste à ce que le droit
français puisse s'appliquer et je crois
que c'est même chose pour pour le rat
donc tout est très bien réglé
c'est-à-dire qu'ils n'ont ils ont
renoncé à l'héritage oui je revenir sur
la dette parce que la dette ça se joue
là en fait ça se joue le 15 décembre la
dette fiscale on l'a vu qui a été ramené
le 34 à 30 millions voilà elle est venue
négocier Laetitia avec le fisc français
en mars ça c'est pas bien passé en
septembre ça s'est mieux passé et là
elle est revenue aussi pour discuter
avec le fils parce que le 15 décembre
elle doit régler la première traite elle
continue quand même à percevoir
l'ensemble des droits elle est quand
même titulaire et de l'intégralité des
droits musicaux qui sont importants
Johnny n'était pas auteur on est
compositeur de ça change tout
il était éditeur il obtenait le droit
d'édiction c'est des chansons plusieurs
millions je pense oui ça représente je
crois a priori à peu près un million par
an c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]